foreign
is with us in Denver Colorado hi Evan
how are you
good Dave how are you doing better than
I deserve how can we help
yeah I see a lot of people are turning
towards artificial intelligence and Robo
advisors to get their financial advice
I was curious to see what you thought
about that is that a good thing or a bad
thing I know from what I played around
with it they don't necessarily say your
advice is bad but they don't disagree
with it or agree with it
um I know particularly they say there is
such thing as good debt and that the
best way to get out of debt is a debt
Avalanche
well I mean you just got to decide who
you want to be advising you chat bot or
human
I just I see a lot of financial advisors
putting it into their practices I was
just wondering is it a dangerous thing
is it a good thing yeah it's both
um Ai and Robo investing is is good it's
there's nothing wrong with any of it
um especially where you're dealing with
a very small account and you're just
getting started and it causes you at a
low cost to get started as an investor
but if I was managing a million dollars
am I letting a chat bot do that no no
don't think so
yeah really I mean AI stuff's very
impressive
um we were I was looking at a meeting
this morning some of the stuff that
we're going to be able to do with it
it's uh it's ridiculous yeah uh how how
cool some of this stuff is but with it
comes the danger of no human oversight
and um and that's the the only way you
know if the advice coming out of it is
accurate is you're measuring it against
a human's value system that's the point
and Evan I would tell you that
artificial intelligence is about
knowledge what it lacks is wisdom and
that's what Dave's talking about you're
talking about a guide a human being who
understands principles through
experience and AI is nothing more than a
world-class aggregation tool if you want
to just break it down and so it's
knowledge knowledge knowledge but answer
your question lies in what you said
artificial intelligence it's not wisdom
it's knowledge that has been aggregated
and you need wisdom and it's never going
to replace the human touch so here's the
thing
you are always in charge of your money
not your financial advisor whether it's
AI whether it's Robo whether it's an
individual human being you have to
understand where the money's going you
are in charge of it it's your fault if
it screws up because you let it happen
it's your money and so you know it and
so what that means is if your financial
advisor says oh there's good debt you
need to go borrow on your house you go
huh I need a new financial advisor this
one's an idiot
oh you know you need to go get a
universal life policy oh I need a new
financial advisor this one's an idiot
and so you know you you have to make
those calls because you've already
decided certain things you're going to
do and not going to do and regardless of
who it is that's coming at you whether
it's
which kind of to me it's very
interesting it's almost an oxymoron to
say artificial intelligence it's like
you know like Airline service you know
these things don't go in the same
sentence but anyway the uh but but it is
very impressive and it is a great
aggregator so it's going to be kind of
fun to see what kind of what we can do
with it as a tool uh but is it am I
going to turn my life over to a single
human a robo advisor or an AI chat bot
not a chance I'm in charge of my life
my job to manage it I can listen to what
they have to say and decide if I want to
fire them or not